Jack Dorsey says Noster is
counterculture today and has the
potential to stay that way the open and
wildly decentralized development model
keeps it Punk
um so that that's that's an interesting
assertion because he's saying you know
he's he's kind of saying the medium is
the message here and that just the very
design of Noster is going to keep it
that way it's going to keep that that
punk ethos indefinitely
um do you think that's right or is it
going to a kind of evolve new Norms as
the user base if and when the user base
grows when I learn about Noster it was
like a little bit too early and and you
know these guys were playing that I was
too busy Bitcoin and then I think it
came back a few months ago I was like
okay holy crap like this thing is really
sort of like now the clients work Wheels
done was like this is great
um and uh I think Jack joined uh as well
and you know like he he sort of did a
bit of an infusion of uh of uh cash and
uh and attention and uh and that project
sort of like taken off like it's working
um and uh it's it's been it's been a
blast here's an example of I think this
post from Odell uh really distills down
the Noster culture uh it's gonna make no
sense to anybody who has not been on the
network Pura Vita stay humble and stack
sets and then kind of hang hang loose
Emoji underneath there it says PV hang
loose uh what does any of that mean
go ahead will
you integrated into the client so Jack
has had a huge influence on at least the
dumbest client so you know so right when
he started joining he would do the the
Shaka the Hang Loose Emoji to every
person who joined So eventually we
change the like button to uh which was
the heart on Twitter we changed it to
the shotgun so it's like because it
makes more sense and and Jack agreed is
like well you know it's just anyway
um so you know the culture is kind of
like getting is evolving and we're kind
of integrating into the client over time
and puravita I think is a term from uh
you know
Costa Rica or something where it just
means Pure Life and it's I don't know it
just it kind of took it just it took off
and now we use up everything and so it's
got that uh you know it's a positive
attitude Master like laid back vibe to
it that's uh and it's I mean it seems
like a a bit of surfer culture kind of
thrown in in a positive way you know I
think we should definitely bring up to
this audience that uh Jack was uh like a
Walmart greeter uh uh for uh for like
pretty much everybody who joined on the
first on the on the big wave that came
in what was it three four three months
ago two months ago uh it was it was fun
to see uh say to you the fact that the
founder of Twitter is certainly it's
he's got to be the most high profile
backer he certainly put you know the
most money uh into the project what does
Jack dorsey's involvement mean for
Noster
it's validating right I mean you know
we'll like you closely like more working
oh yeah um yeah it's interesting because
you know he he said this is what this
was a big post that he did on Austria
he's like this is what Twitter felt like
at 5 000 users but better and so I feel
like Jack this is kind of what he always
wanted to build is an open Free Speech
protocol that's like real time it
reminds him a lot like it's nostalgic to
him from the early days of Twitter when
um because nachos actually was very much
like what it felt like in the early days
of Twitter more real time and like open
protocol open apis so I think he's like
yeah nostalgic and he just wants to you
know he wants to like take that ex what
he had in the early days of Twitter and
he and then relive it and not sure and
build it out so it's kind of cool yeah
sorry guys like what's really cool is
that like he is contributing a lot
financially too to a lot of projects uh
and and like but the community itself is
doing as well uh we actually have a
website bound sir sr.org where people
put bounties uh for features and
projects and people are building like
this habla.new news and there were
others so uh so if you're a Dev out
there watching this uh do go check out
and participate a couple of years ago at
the Bitcoin Miami Conference uh Alex
Gladstone of Human Rights Foundation
interviewed Jack Dorsey who I you know I
think I I find Jack Dorsey to be the
most inspiring and very Tech leader that
we have and he was talking about how
Twitter never should become the platform
where people speak but it should you
know the the internet or there should be
a Twitter of Twitter's there should just
be you know a kind of a Utopia of
Utopias
um you know it's a very libertarian very
dispersed very decentralized things two
questions part of the power of Twitter
and this is also true of Facebook and
before it was true of you know AOL uh
back when it had a Walled Garden is that
it is a place where lots and lots of
people are and is there is there a
necessary trade-off between the size of
the audience which gives things a lot of
power and a lot of meaning and the
ability to kind of control your
experience or to have maximum freedom is
that just is that just a trade-off
that's one question and then the second
one is there a way that you can see or
or has Jack Dorsey talked about this of
integrating Nostra with Twitter so that
you can you you know you can participate
in Twitter without having to worry about
you know Elon Musk as a sugar Spa you
know blood sugar Spike and blocks you
forever and ever and like oh you know
the past 10 years or 15 years of your
life is just locked away from
you forever
um so so like first of all protocol
shouldn't be companies right they should
be an open protocol that anybody Builds
on top
um yes Twitter could create a client
could create a relay tomorrow and I mean
like Peter could literally push all the
tweets into a relay as the author or
they could you know go really the proper
route and create like a key pair for
each user and sort of like go that
direction so yes it's totally possible
that they could participate in this but
at least in my view like most people
don't want freedom most people just want
a better sell so you have to give people
tools for them to sort of like censor
the things they want to censor for
themselves and you know and we're going
to see this we're gonna see relays where
it's like I don't know like PG-13 right
a PG-13 relay where you know you follow
those guidelines and you're okay if your
kids go on that relay and and that's
sort of like the the moral set that you
have and but but the key here is choice
right uh it's not preventing the people
who do want freedom to have that freedom
hey thanks for watching that excerpt
from our conversation with nvk and will
casarin about nostrip and the future of
the decentralized web check out the full
interview in the description below and
tune in every Thursday at 1pm Eastern to
catch these conversations Live And
subscribe to recent TV and hit the
notifications Bell to find out anytime
our videos go live